Australian Andy Stafford and two friends
were flown high into the Owls for an
adventure film but this time they chose
the wrong mountain and the wrong
challenge
suddenly the entire slope gives way
there's no outrunning the monster as
tons of snow come crashing down the hill
at over 150 miles per hour
as soon as it when I thought I'm dead
that's it it's all over and it sound
like someone dropped a bomb on us the
whole thing fractured heavily and it was
a la large large cracking sound and I
mean I pretty much knew immediately that
the whole thing broke up suddenly the
whole thing was moving underneath I'm
the one on the top left hand side and I
thought I'd go down and get out to the
left the left hand side I was getting us
speed but I guess I didn't realize it's
ever laughs getting close to about 250
kill me as an hour plus that's pretty
much why me right yelled and screamed
and and rolled all the rest the way down
incredibly all three skiers survived
their brush with death
you